warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised because of um how
I was going mentally um
I I wasn't coping because I had such a
so through it all because I had such a
low self-image um and self-worth through
it all um that I would have got to the
point where I would have just I
I guess we touch another issue there but
I I actually got to the point where I
was suicidal um and so I would have
either go on the divorce route or I
would have I would have left in that
respects um and so God God kept us going
and so I honestly don't know how people
go through it all without God I I can't
comprehend that because of the direction
I was heading already um yeah
welcome everyone to another episode of
LED live we hear so many times as we go
around to different places speaking how
you all will join us either on a Friday
night or different times of the day it's
kind of surreal uh when you think about
that when you're sitting in our seat and
so we're humbled and blessed to invite
you into this
conversation and today we have a guest
her name is Samantha and she's all the
way in Australia so she got up early
this morning to be with us in the
afternoon and Samantha is the wife of
someone who had a pornography addiction
so we're going to talk about that today
so if that's been your experience or you
know somebody who's had that or maybe
you've been a pornography addict
yourself that's the things we're going
to talk about so welcome and come on in
pull up a seat and uh be a part of the
conversation today so we got Mike and
denique and this is Sam as she likes to
go by so Sam welcome thank you for
joining us today and for being a part of
this program and reaching out to us and
we want to understand this topic better
uh for ourselves and for those people
that are watching so thank you for doing
this so I guess the the the place you
know they always say the best place to
start is the beginning right
so um
where does this journey for you start I
mean it I'm I'm guessing you probably
didn't know before you got
married actually I did you did okay now
I'm surprised we're all that is so you
knew that was a problem but you got
married
anyway yeah I was very naive and
arrogant okay going into the marriage
were you a Christian when you got
married yes okay yeah okay yeah so uh
long story short um I left God I came
back to God and I had been um back
building my relationship with God for
probably 5 years before I met
Nel
and I was very
um I guess because I had failed
relationships in the past I was very
adamant that I wasn't going to get
married and um but if you know there was
potential then um I had very strict
rules in regards to what that looked
like so even before uh he asked me to be
his girlfriend um I was very blunt with
him in regards of like if this is H the
direction that it's looking like you
know you need to know that um I'm not a
virgin and so that's who I am you know
leave take it or leave it I'm quite
happy if he didn't want to pursue me
anymore because of that and he was
actually very gracious and uh he said to
me well there's something you need to
know about me and that I'm struggling
with pornography wow and I was like oh
okay and so he kind of gave me the same
option um and so we still decided to
pursue each other and um start dating
for marriage and I was very naive in
regards of I thought in my head that
once we got married that it would stop
because I would be satisfying the need
in some
respects and so but I was very wrong
that's kind of where it all started from
that perspective how did you or at what
point in your marriage did you
realize this isn't stopping it's not
going to way and it is a problem that
needs to be addressed how much time are
we talking
about so it was about 12 months um we
had been married 12 months and I hadn't
actually asked him the question um
directly about whether he was still
using or not
and so I was kind of Happily ignorant
because I guess in some respects we had
a very active sex life and so I the
thought didn't even cross my head that
he was still using and so yeah it was
after 12 months I actually kind of
approached the topic kind of tentatively
and asked the question whether how he
was going with it we hadn't talked about
it um and that's when he said that he
had still been using and I just lost it
I just broke down and cried and yeah but
he was honest with me after 12 months so
that was nice when I asked him yeah wow
yeah I I find that um I'm thinking of
some people who as married couples that
might be both agreeing to watch
pornography either together or just
being okay with the other spouse um and
you know and in this case you said you
know you were having a well an active
sex life
for those people who watching and I'm
just trying to kind of answer their
question they might say well look you
had an active you had a good active sex
life and we have an active sex life but
we both agreed to watch pornography
what's the harm could you kind of answer
that question for people who might
be sure um so basically the cut and
thrust of it is that um even if you are
actively watching pornography together
um as a married couple
by biblical standards that if you lust
after a woman in your heart then you
have committed adultery already and
so my response to that is well God
created uh sex as a very intimate part
of a married couple and so that sort of
thing to be able to Broach into watching
pornography together both of you in my
perspective the Bible is very clear in
regards of you're both actually
committing adultery in your heart
because it's also where your mind's at
and where your attitude and your
intention of why you actually have sex
um and so that is is very important as
well and so yeah that's kind of it's all
about in the head if that makes sense
yeah yeah yeah I uh um I really like
following fight the new drug I don't
know if you're familiar with them no I'm
not so fight the new drug is a
non-religious non-legislative and non
Aly biased
organization that um is is like
literally they're not Christian but they
speak against
pornography um and they have they're
they're pretty well known now in the US
they have their own podcast they have um
they Advocate against the use of
pornography and so I I checked some of
their resources and some of the things
they say is that how pornography is
really bad for the brain um it increases
violence and very often people will also
um copy whatever they're watching in
pornography and bring it into their own
sex life which is you usually just not
even close to being
realistic you know and they have these
expectations of their spouse that are
just actually really harmful um so I
find that really interesting and I
totally agree with you that it's it's um
for many reasons it's it's very
unhealthy uh for one's sex
life yeah well actually there was um I
remember before I got married I remember
reading a news article um of a bloke who
um he was addicted to pornography and he
actually masturbated like over 20 times
a day and it ended up killing him like
there was a direct correlation between
him doing that and his death um so that
was very interesting reading that too
that's crazy wow so you said that you
were kind of naive and ignorant when
this happened you didn't see any kind of
red flags or anything anything in your
marriage like in your sex life or
anything that made you think why are you
doing that or anything not initially um
I think because in the first four months
of marriage you're very
um uh honeymoon phase right and so I was
kind of I had rosecolor glasses on and
was quite happy to be ignorant I guess
about it um and I guess because I didn't
actually have um a proper
conversation specifically about it with
someone that I trusted
about you know what are things to be
expect and um as much as I had a very
supportive family and my family was very
open about talking about sex I guess I
kind of didn't broach the topic more
specifically about um pornographies and
looking at red flags and um but yeah I
was so blissfully ignorant um that I
didn't even pick up on the Red Flags um
it wasn't until after that um the
initial 12 months after that that I
actually started picking up on some more
red flags cuz we've been married now for
over 5 years and so it's been from there
that I started to actually click it's
like oh hang on a minute when this
happens you know it can indicate that
he's using and so so do you have any
examples off the top of your head can
you name any of those examples of the
red flags yeah actually um specifically
when he said uh no to sex to me um was
generally
um an indicator especially if we hadn't
had sex in like a week or so wow um
because he would um like we I guess I'm
trying to go into how much detail I give
generally we we would be having sex on
like you know two three times a week
sort of thing but you know if something
happened and we just hadn't got there um
sort of thing if I then um start to
pursue him in that regards um and he
says no to me especially if we you know
if he's not long had a shower or you
know you know we're not long getting
into bed sort of thing um that would be
an indication to me it's like oh okay
something happened while he was
showering that um because usually um it
takes him a little bit to get going
after he's done the once sort of thing
and so those kind of were red flags to
me in regards of
um the fact that he would deny me if
that makes sense and like he has every
right to say no to sex just as much as I
have every right to say no to sex
depends on the day and um what's been
going on um but that was one of the
examples um that I picked up on it
sounds like what you're alluding to if
I'm understanding you correctly is the
pornography was now also responsible for
leading
to um a solo sexual
experience where you were not um Wanted
or desired because he had already had
that you know temporary physical
fulfillment and did you know that that
was part
of um the pornography experience did you
know that from the get-go or did it take
you a little while to figure that out
took me a little bit to figure that out
um to be able to put the pieces of it
together um especially because I didn't
talk to anybody okay um especially in
depth in regards of you know what does
it look like sort of thing um I know
that at the same time um through all
this he was feeling extremely guilty and
ashamed because um like as we've gone
through our journey he's voiced these
things because he would feel very um
very guilty about not being able to then
satisfy me in some respects because he
was content he was he was happy with
what he had done and so because he's
always been a fan believer in regards of
um that in a marriage that the husband
should satisfy the wife um he was
feeling quite a lot of guilt and shame
when he did say no to me on the times
where he had used so how how did it
impact you emotionally when this all uh
went
on um very badly yeah so I was feeling
very unworthy I wasn't feeling
attractive I wasn't feeling like I was
being up to the standard as a wife
should be I felt like that I wasn't um
cuz I'm a little bit of a chunkier girl
I wouldn't say you super overweight but
I'm
chunkier um and so I then brought back
the struggles I was having because I was
not the ideal body type as the world
standards so yeah I was feeling yeah
very much not good enough as a wife not
attractive there must be something wrong
with me
um you know how he how could he do this
to me when you know he vowed that he
would love me and not hurt me and all
these things and you know I I came
across this female um through fight the
new drugs social media actually or it
might have been through their podcast
consider before consuming um and she has
her own Instagram where she uh talks
very openly about her experiences with
her husband when he was addicted to
pornography and um and I recently saw a
post from her where she said that
apparently uh because of his pornography
uh pornography consumption she felt the
need to put in breast implants and it
even got that far that the breast
implants started merging with her own
breast tissue and she need to get
surgery done to get it removed praise
the Lord that he um came to a conclusion
that pornography was not what he was
supposed to be doing he was hurting his
wife and he quit and that they're both
openly advocating against it but you
know if really shows how much of an
emotional impact this kind of um
Behavior I actually has you know yeah so
it's not a victimless crime as I say
it's not just like well this is just
it's only me what she doesn't know won't
hurt her or whatever uh there's there's
a Fallout that comes with being addicted
to pornography where your wife isn't
feeling like she measures up or can
satisfy her husband the way the the porn
is or whatever so it's yeah it's
definitely harmful for relationships mhm
throughout our marriage life um I did a
lot of Crash diets and so to try and fit
the norm what what do you mean by crash
diet like where you just diet really
hard and it doesn't end up working is
that what a crash diet is yes yes so um
I remember I went on this um particular
diet where I had to take these
supplements and I cut all cut out all
carbs and everything and I lost like oh
I think it was about 12 kilos in the
space of about six weeks wow and yet it
was not not healthy at all and then you
of course you bounce back and then you
add the extra weight that you've um lost
as well so that's kind of crashed di so
I did a lot of that there's there's I
think what you have is and is probably
the typical human response probably
anybody would feel that way but I think
it's interesting that you start to
absorb the guilt upon yourself even
though he was the one that really had
the problem and so automatically you
start taking the blame for an act that
he's the one choosing to do that's kind
of a an interesting psychological
phenomenon I think a lot of people do
that I'm not saying it's right but it's
it's fascinating how the mind works and
you know we'll think that we're the
problem it must be us you know it could
it's not it's not their fault you know
that kind of thing okay so you you kind
of go in you go into your marriage your
your eyes are I guess both pretty wide
open you might say at least as wide open
as you you know that they are you
realize this becomes a problem are you
both where are you at in your religious
experience are you both going to
church um do you have you know
surrounded by supportive friends and
family like what does that look like at
the time that you confront him and
everything kind of blows up so Al was
kind of of a um a prolonged journey in
the respects of until he got help um so
after the first 12 months we were um
actively going to church um I probably
wasn't going to church as often as he
was actually because um I was working a
lot okay um so I was I was working you
know between 40 and 45 hours a week and
so I was just exhausted by the time SS
came
around so um he was actually going to
church more than I was um and we we
actually lived in bunder BG in
Queensland and I had moved there by
myself um I knew of some friends up
there and so we were basically around um
his support network so his family his
friends as much as they became my family
and my friends um there're still a
slightly different Dynamic um when you
come into that kind of circle yeah um
I'm not entirely sure um how many of
these friends or which ones of them knew
that um this is what he was dealing with
because um my husband's quite a he's bit
more of an introvert um and so to talk
about like deeply personal things with
his close friends can be a bit of a
challenge for him so I'm not entirely
sure at what point um one of his close I
know by Midway through one of his close
friends definitely knew I just wasn't
entirely sure when that was broached
with them so I was basically up there
kind of basically by myself um there was
one of my friends that I could talk to
cuz her husband was going through a
similar thing but because she was in the
midst of it I couldn't get really any
kind of support or help from
her um and so and I didn't tell my
parents either I have a very close
relationship with my family but they
were you know 11 OD hours travel away
from me and so it was all phone calls
and and like FaceTime and things like
that and yeah I didn't I didn't talk to
my family at all about what was going on
and so I basically had no support um my
only support was basically God and Me
struggling with with God in regards of
like how does this work and you know how
does my relationship with you equate to
the fact that my husband's doing this
you know does that mean you know because
my husband's doing this does that make
me less in your sight God and um so
that's kind of where I was at with with
my relationship with God and um my
churchgoing experience um so I wouldn't
say that I was actively studying the
Bible um but I was definitely there was
a lot of prayer and um yeah there was
still that aspect of kind of trying to
figure out how my relationship with God
works through all this so so how did it
impact your relationship with the Lord
was it like you know a struggle to trust
him because of it or yeah I'm just
curious so it's um in a lot of respects
it drove me to more prayer but it
basically I guess in some respects I
somewhat blamed God because I'm like you
gave me this husband and he's doing this
what am I meant to do with this um so I
guess it not so much broke down a little
bit of trust with me and God it was more
of a trying to understand why why why
this was happening and you know God I'm
not strong enough to be able to deal
with this and cope with this um so I
guess in looking back at it it's kind of
it drew me closer to God in some
respects but in other respects it kind
of I pushed away a bit too I'm curious
when you said that you actually
questioned if this was something that
was coming on you in your spiritual life
like you wondered if my husband is doing
this is this a reflection on me in your
sight so like we were talking about it's
not a victimless crime it's even
affecting your spiritual life in a sense
that you wonder if yeah maybe it's
coming between you and
God that's just interesting I never
thought about that
before did you feel like you were in
some way
um what's the word like enabling it or
something because you were I don't know
not addressing it sooner or something um
I guess in some respects you could look
at that way in regards of enabling
because I didn't um for myself I didn't
seek help and I didn't speak out about
it um like I would like you know every
couple of months I would ask him are you
you still using like are you you know
looking at pornography masturbation and
um he would give me kind of non-direct
answers he'd be like oh you know I'm
struggling with it a little bit or you
know I've been pretty good this week or
something like that I guess you have a
couple of questions now that I'm I'm
thinking through all this
um one is at what
point did you decide or seek like some
substantial help
and who did you go to did you go to like
an online resource did you talk to
somebody in person and I'm not
discounting like your experience with
God wasn't good enough that I mean you
might tell us no it was God all the way
I didn't ever go to anybody that's fine
I'm just trying to figure out at what
point did things start changing for the
better because you came to a point where
you can work through it um well
unfortunately it had to change for the
worst before it actually changed for the
better okay um because it wasn't until I
think at our threeyear marriage Mark um
that um we ended up moving so where I'm
currently living is in um kuna Baran in
New South Wales
Australia and um we moved out here with
my family because my family bought
property and um my husband and I we kind
of didn't know what we were doing at
that point um because of all Co and
stuff and so um and so we moved out here
with with them and was helping out on
their property and um I guess in some
respects I just got to the breaking
point um where like all the all through
our marriage so far I had been asking
him and checking on him in regards of
how are you doing it might be a good
idea for you to get help and and he was
like no no I'm I'm fine I'm I'm I'm
doing it with God and I you know God and
I I sort it out sort of thing and in my
head and my doesn't look like a sort of
thing um and so once we moved out here
um he um I guess the I asked him again
at one point when we're living out here
you know how are you going with it are
you still using I was very direct and he
said yes um
and I had got to the point where I'm
like you know what I'm I'm tired of this
I'm tired of feeling like this I'm tired
of feeling that I'm good enough enough
and that you know you still feel the
desire to go to that when you know I'm
right here sort of thing and so um
coming up to that point he had actually
told me um so I I need to tell this part
a little bit my mom and I are very good
friends as much as she's my mom um she's
been my best friend for a long time and
I would talk to her about anything and
everything but um up until the point
where ID had enough Nathaniel had
actually said to me don't talk to your
mom about this um not in a mean way but
in the way that he was ashamed and so if
he thought that if my parents found out
then you know it would he would feel the
guilt and the shame and all that kind of
stuff associated with it even more so
yeah and so he had told me that I was
allowed to talk to my mom and um and so
at that threeyear Mark I I'd had enough
and so I spoke to my mom about it and I
said look this is what I'm dealing with
I can't do this you know I don't know
what to do and we had a really good chat
about it um and then the next day I had
um I was about to finish work and I got
a text message from my dad and I knew
that my mom would talk to my dad I have
a very good relationship with my dad as
well and my dad sent me a message saying
hey I'm just outside your work can we
have a chat and so I went out and had a
chat with him I knew what we going to
talk about and it was really good he's
my dad's such a blessing because he's
very direct and he just sat down with me
and he just asked me straight he goes
Sam do you want to save your marriage
I'm like yes I do and so then he kind of
guided me through regards of the things
that I needed to do to be able to make
Nathaniel accountable for his
actions um which was unfortunately
because Nathaniel was in such denial and
didn't want to get outside help even
though he really needed it um my dad
advised me for us to separate for a time
for him to be able to realize that
what he's doing is not acceptable um
it's not acceptable to God it's not
acceptable to me um and it's kind of
it's it was ruining our marriage um
because ultimately if if he wasn't going
to get help and if he wasn't going to
stop then I kind of was at my wt's end
sort of thing so yeah so we I went home
and I spoke to him and um praise God
that he he broke down and cried and was
like I don't want to be like this
anymore and so um it was really
difficult because it was Silling amongst
covid and all that that getting outside
help from um like even going to see
someone as much as you know Zoom is very
accessible and things like that um it is
still difficult to kind of get help in
that
respect um so that was kind of the point
there where I had to actually give him
an ultimatum in regards of you know when
need to separate for you to be a to get
help because you're not actively getting
help now um and I didn't want to leave
my husband I didn't want to kick him out
I didn't want to do any of those things
but because he wasn't being held
accountable for his actions and taking
the steps to actually get the help he
needed to be able to stop I felt like I
had no other choice and honestly he was
being unfaithful I mean it's it's not
just yeah I mean let's not try and
sugarcoat it you know yeah it's adultery
yeah did you have any children actually
no we don't have children and we still
don't and I actually praise God that we
don't have children because I don't know
how I would have coped through all of
this if we had
kids because it was such it was taking
such a mental load on me um I praise God
that we didn't have children CU I don't
know how I would have gone being a
mother through all of that so what did
the recovery slash healing SL
realization process look like for him
during that separation what is he doing
to make you know realistic steps towards
recovery so um again because
unfortunately in amongst covid um he
couldn't really go far and so because we
live on a property here he actually like
I I said to him that you know he we had
to not be in the same bedroom together
anymore um and so he actually decided to
live in the back of his youth a pick
pickup truck for the Americans was
say yeah yeah it had like a canopy on it
and everything so it was like fully
enclosed um so he's still um we we live
in a very communal family kind of
situation here and so he's still ate
with the family and all that um but he
he and I were very separated in the
respects of he he did his own laundry I
didn't cook for him he didn't get to
know where I was going what I was doing
and vice versa because you know if he
was living elsewhere he wouldn't know
those things right and so we were very
much um separate from that respect and
so you know I said to Nathaniel that he
needs to get help um anyway my um my dad
is actually um really good at helping um
couples and individual through really
tough times and so I said to Nathaniel
look you can find the the route of
finding a counselor or you know you can
talk to my dad he's willing to help you
if you want that's completely up to you
um because he also had a really good
relationship with my dad as well and so
he decided that um he was going to get
help through my dad um and my dad has
actually celled um before in this
specific um area as well um but it's a
specific program for people who are
struggling with pornography and
masturbation um it basically you go
through it once we have a meeting once a
week and you go through the
program um so that's kind of where it
started for Nathaniel to be able to get
help is that he had to actively make the
appointments and actively do the program
which he had to restart twice no restart
he had to restart it one time because he
wasn't really clicking with it like he
wasn't being genuine I guess the right
word is with it he was just kind of like
being a bit robotic with his answers and
everything so was your dad the one that
had him restart or did he voluntarily do
that well it was basically a um
throughout all of this um we were having
meetings as well like counseling
sessions um like I was getting um some
help from my mom because my mom has
developed a um depression anxiety
program um for it was actually
specifically for kids and so I was
getting helped through that to be able
to deal with um my side of things but at
one point um I think it was about a
month and a half in um we had a meeting
and dad was very blunt with him in the
regards
of this is how your answers are looking
um this is not a it just looks like
you're going through the motions to try
and win back your wife sort of thing but
it's not actually helping you um and so
dad gave him the choice he he's like you
either go find someone else to help you
um or you restart the program and
actually be very genuine and kind of get
more heartfelt and more like you have to
dig deep to be able to actually answer
these questions properly and honestly to
be able to actually get to a point where
you can
overcome um because he had such an
emotional disconnect yeah that's really
amazing I'm sitting here thinking about
you know your parents
and for them to be very
objective and just be like we want to
help this guy like I'm trying to think
of myself as a parent like right if my
daughter's you know husband came to me
and was like you know I've had a
pornography problem would I really feel
like helping him or would I be like
tough luck buddy go you know hit the
road yeah um you know and I don't I and
I'm not saying I would react that way
but you you wonder it's like they were
really truly being a parent to him after
he became part of your life and saying
these are both my children and really
seeking to help him which is awesome I
mean that's the way it should be yeah
but unfortunately it doesn't always work
that way and they could have told him to
just take a hike or or something but
that's that's pretty awesome that it
that it worked out that way the love of
Christ yeah so that's that's really
cool um so you're working through this
process how long does it take before he
graduates essentially and and then how
long does it take for you is it kind of
simultaneous or does it take one longer
than the other um I think it really
depended on it depends on the person and
depends on their willingness I guess so
the program itself the road to recovery
um that he went through it's an 8we
course um it can take longer if need be
like if you have to review stuff on a
regular basis or not um so as much as
the program itself is only 8 weeks
long um he had to basically we had to
date again essentially so he had to W me
again um so as much as the course was
only eight weeks long
um there was still that building of
trust and the building of um the fact
that if he was actually genuine or
whether he was just going through the
motions and just kind of Faking it I
guess um because I completely lost Trust
of him because essentially he had lied
to me through um our marriage thus far
because he never was truly honest with
me in regards of how he was dealing with
it because he always gave me kind of
obliv like um not oblivious but dodging
your dodging your questions was it like
what was it like for both of you guys to
kind of almost like I said date each
other again and fall in love again I can
imagine that's really hard because it's
not like it's not like the original
version of that story where it's like oh
it's exciting and it's fun and I don't
know where this is going to go it's like
that but it's you know like I know what
you did yeah like this is I don't I
don't know if I trust you and how long
were you physically separated too we
were separated for six months um they
were it was a combination of the
honeymoon phase again as well as the
whole hey I don't trust you yet sort of
thing um because there were times where
he actually he organized really romantic
dates and you know he actively pursued
me and so you know you have those you
know those moments of butterflies and
like oh okay he's making the effort sort
of thing um like you do when you're
initially dating but there's always in
the back of my head like you know is he
being genuine is he actually um you know
going through the doing what he's needs
to do to be able to get help himself
sort of thing um looking back I think it
probably would have been better for me
if we hadn't been separated slightly
longer because I was still struggling
with
um everything in my own head and to be
able to regain trust with him again um I
was really struggling with so he was
during the first six months he was you
actively implementing um the things in
the program for himself as well because
like there was things involved in
regards of like answering really
personal questions and he had to do a
journal and um you know he had to look
at it from a very biblical perspective
um and kind of works through the program
that way which then he kind of had to
continue through even after the program
stopped like he still had um not super
regular check-ins um with my dad but
like check-ins in the respects of um you
know every few weeks or something I
can't remember how long exactly it was
he actively pursued me but there was a
point in that process where for me my
prayer changed because all the while
through of course you know you're
praying for him um but my active prayer
was Lord give me back my husband you
know I want my husband back you know I
love him and all that but you know he's
done this to me and
D you know I want him to be okay but you
know give me back my husband and so it
was this particular day where emotions
were really high and um it got the point
where um Nathaniel he took off he ran
into the bush cuz he was broken
essentially and I I thought that I had
lost him I thought that he was never
coming back to me um and I was just
crying and Bing my eyes out and my dad
was really most my parents are really
supportive but my dad's like look just
let him be he just needs time to kind of
re-evaluate things just kind of you know
he hasn't gone you haven't lost him and
so I took a deep breath and I went and
sat on the back of um my car
and I was just praying and that moment
it was a really um it was such a close
moment with God and I because my prayer
changed from you know from Lord give me
back my husband to Lord even if you
don't give him back to me as long as
he's right with you that's all that
matters
right and I think that was a big turning
point for me because it went from me
being like I want this I want this I
want this to actually being like Lord no
he's
yours you have him sort of thing and I'm
yours and so as long as I'm okay with
you as well that's all that matters um
so my prayer changed from that point um
to giving him to God because we are
meant to be you know the I guess the
hierarchy in some respects of you know
you put God
first um not not your husband first and
I think at that point I was putting my
husband over
God um because I was putting such
emphasis on our
marriage um and so from that point on my
prayer changed and so for me my healing
process changed for the better um
because I looked at myself than more as
a daughter of God properly and more as a
fact that hey you know God wants me to
respect myself and he wants me to have
standards and he wants me to be able to
live a full and happy life so no matter
what happens with my marriage I am a
daughter of God I am worthy because he
made me worthy and that really kind of
for me to change that in my head um yeah
helped a lot for my healing
process so I'm
guessing are there
still
regular like check-ins is there still
like some active monitoring that's going
on or is it like you both are in a
position of full trust at this point
everything is healed there's no you
don't feel like it's necessary to check
in because I know there's some people I
mean I don't know it's kind of
like
um you know how somebody's once they've
committed a crime it can be difficult
for them to get a job right and there
are some like Second Chance employers
but a lot of people won't take a look at
them the second time because of that
first off
and so how far has that
carried and you know where do you I
guess where do you stand today do he
have like monitoring software on his
phone or computer I mean did you ever do
that where where are things at today
yeah so actually when when we first
separated
um I actually asked him for his because
he had an iPhone and he had an iPad and
so I actually asked for those things um
and he had every right to say no to me
like that was his prerogative um but he
actively gave those things up um and I
then
um for for a little bit I actually kept
them in in my room um to be able to keep
them away from him because he knew those
were his triggers and so but it got to a
point where I actually then handed it
off to Mom and Dad um because I didn't I
kept seeing them and so I'm like I don't
want them um and so he was basically cut
off from all his technology because he
um those were his triggers because it
was so accessible um and the job at the
time also he had just finished up um a
job as well so he didn't actually
require any technology at that point um
because he was um Contracting out at
that point um and so he then to be able
to talk to anyone um he then got a um as
you call it a dumb phone so basically
not a smartphone a phone that didn't
have any access to Internet or anything
like that um and his mom actually sent
that to him um because she wanted to
check in with him of course as well um
and so he didn't have any for a good
solid few months he didn't really have
any access to um the internet or
technology um but if you did need to go
on like for example if you need to go on
eBay or something um he would be in the
house in the main house cuz my our where
we're living my um Nathaniel and my room
is separated from the main
house um and
so because I didn't want to be in a room
alone with him either um he then he
could use the computer in the main house
with the rest of the family because we
have a big family here living here um so
that way you know he was kind of kept
accountable in that respects um and so
that's how it kind of started and then
even now after all this time I'm I still
don't trust him fully and um I haven't
been shy with that either um in letting
him know that not that I'm cruel or
anything but I would just kind of be
like you know if he would say something
or something like that I'd be like look
honey I just I'm still not comfortable
with that and he would be very gracious
and he's he's he's very he's been very
great in that respect is he he's like
you take as much time as you need to be
able to be okay with me again so even
though we're um yeah we're two years on
basically because we've married now just
over 5 years he's still very gracious
and he hasn't done anything to be able
to not make me trust him um and so that
trust is slowly building again and so he
has actually chosen not to get his
iPhone back he has actually chosen to
keep a dumb phone because he knows for
him that's a trigger for him um even he
did contemplate the idea of the software
that you can get online and everything
to be able to monitor stuff he didn't
even want to try because he knew it was
such a Temptation for me for him that he
was like no I'm just going to stick to
this phone it's working for me all I
need to do is send out text messages and
make phone calls with it you know he has
the iPad that he has which he um isn't
in a room alone um with it with internet
access
and so he has actually chosen to um just
keep things that way um so there's a
point now where like you know of course
we're back living in our room again and
so I'll be if he's sitting in the middle
of the day like doing stuff on eBay or
sending emails or something I'm in and
out constantly and we're actually at the
point where I'm okay with that whereas
previously I was like no you need to go
and sit in the house where there's
people if I'm in and out all the time um
whereas now I'm a bit more comfortable
in the respects of um we've built up
that trust where he can be in the room
on his iPad and I'll be in and out
constantly doing chores or something um
so that's what it kind of looks like in
regards of Technology wise um to be able
to help the temptation of um and he's
still very honest with me in the
respects of which is great um because
I'll ask him it went from like nearly
every week to now you know every couple
of weeks to sort of thing like how are
you going with it um and I'm very direct
um and he'll actually be honest with me
and he'll broach the topic sometimes in
regards of you know Sam I was really
tempted this morning after you left for
work um but I just you know picked up my
Bible and started reading or I went into
the house or you know I then you know
went and did some work in the yard or
something um so that's kind of where
it's been it's been a gradual increase
of trust um so so you guys are both
Christians um how has God come into play
in all of this and in the saving and
restoring of your marriage um God has
been a major influence um and a major
factor in it all in the respects of it
drove him to God um more so um and for
me as well it drove me to God more so um
but it's a a daily Reliance on God so
previously to this I guess you could say
we were kind
of as much as we were trying to be
Christians and trying to have our
relationship with God and all that kind
of stuff and you know doing the things
going through the motions and all that
kind of stuff um and trying to build a
relationship with God I think that it
was still slightly
disconnected um but through this
experience I think it's made God more
real and the fact that now because
previously we would let our morning
devotion slip or we would let our you
know morning prayer together slip um but
now we're very intentional in regards of
no we need to seek God first every
morning um and so we have prayer
together um so we pray together a lot um
so yeah God has been a such we needed to
rely on him through everything and we
had promises um in the Bible that we
rely on like um you know Philippians
4:13 I can do all things through Christ
who strengthens me um you know Psalms
121: um 1 and 2 says you know I lift up
my eyes into the hills from whence come
my help my help comes from the Lord the
maker of heaven and Earth and so those
promises became very real to us um yeah
so that it pushed us towards God so so
how different do you think your
experience would have been if you guys
maybe weren't a Christian and having to
gone through this without God we would
have been divorced to be honest wow so
so your faith really kept you going and
kept you together yeah yeah because of
um how I was going mentally um
I I wasn't coping because I had such a
so through it all because I had such a
low self-image um and self-worth through
it all um that I would have got to the
point where I would have just
I I guess we touch another issue there
but I I actually got to the point where
I was suicidal um and so I would have
either gone the divorce route or I would
have I would have left in that
respect um and so God God kept us going
and so I honestly don't know how people
go through it all without God I I can't
comprehend that because of the direction
I was heading already um yeah wow I
think it really speaks to you know when
you talk about going through the motions
and and there probably are a lot of
people that go through the
motions um it's that
Western
Society mindset of Revelation chter 3
where you're rich you're increased with
Goods you don't need
anything when in reality there's
Brokenness and until we come to the
realization that we are
broken we're never going to get the help
we need from Christ and then once you
realize your Brokenness you don't see
how life can go on without Christ
because he brings the healing and the
Hope um yep
so for our audience I guess listening to
your
journey I'm glad you brought out the
promises I thought I was going to I was
going to go there and ask if there were
any bible promises that kind of kept you
going through all of this um if you were
going to give advice to somebody let's
say they they find out they are in your
shoes that you were you know essentially
5 years ago three years ago um let's say
um you're just you're just finding out
that um you're going to get married to
somebody right and you find out they
have this issue
is your advice to them like yeah go
ahead and get married or is it like no
you need to do this this and this first
and then um you know let's say they are
married and they find out they're in the
same situation you're in what is your
advice to
people being on this side of things and
and seeing kind of the the end from the
beginning like you have so for those who
are heading towards marriage and find
out that their partner um um is doing
such whether is either side because
women are susceptible to it as well um I
would strongly advise to hold off
getting married um and actively seeking
the help
required um whether it be from um a a
pastor or a counselor or you know
someone who's very wise um in these kind
of respects um someone who's very
trusted because it is such a sensitive
topic
um and people have these barriers
against this kind of topic um you need
to initially talk to someone that you
can trust um and to be able to get
direction and help because
realistically at the end of the day
pornography and masturbation is an
addiction like any other addiction um
and so even if you get help in regards
of how to overcome addictions
um then that is initial steps that I
would take um I I I can't give time
frames in regards of how long you would
hold off getting married for right um
but honestly in my opinion it should be
as long as it
takes um to be able to get assistance
and then I guess it depends on the
individuals and their willingness and
their openness to be able to work
through it I guess it then depends on
when you do get married I guess in some
respects if you're one of the partners
in that heading towards marriage and
you're like you still have doubts in
regards of whether they've been genuine
in getting help um I think that you
shouldn't be pushed into the situation
of oh well we're engaged already now
like we should just get it done and
we'll just keep on working through it I
think that both parties need to be like
100% okay y they're being genuine you
know we can still work through this sort
of thing so I guess it's it's very
dependent on the individuals because I
guess you look at it in the respects of
like you know okay if you found out that
your um soon to be husband or wife has a
gambling problem you know what would you
do um so I think we need to make sure
that we don't just separate pornography
and masturbation from all other
addictions just because it's a sexual
nature um we need to look at it as a
fact that yeah okay it's an addiction so
how do we get help for this um and then
the to the people that are married get
seek help talk to someone who can help
the situation who can give good guidance
um I have a friend actually um who's
going through all this still and
unfortunately um and and they're
Christians and everything but
unfortunately because he's not willing
to get help and he's not willing to um
be able to overcome Unfortunately they
are Hing the separation and Perman
divorce section because of his
attitude um and she acknowledges the
fact that that she should have spoken
out sooner because not that she's
blaming herself or anything like that
but you know she's gone through you know
over a decade of all this without any
help um and so I I want to really
implore people that if you are going
through this as the person who is
addicted um as much as it will be
painful and it you know can hurt people
and all that kind of stuff be honest and
gets through it because I guess it does
depend on your marriage and how it is
before that as
well
that if you are in a relationship that
is in it for the long haul your partner
will support
you um you know it it might take some
time and it might be really
painful
but to be able to overcome you need help
you need outside help no matter what so
whether that's from you know some of the
resources um that you can get online or
whether it's from a trusted friend or
you know a pastor or something like that
um that can help guide you through it
but to be able to overcome this sort of
thing and keeping your partner in the
dark is I don't think he's healthy
um but if your partner is well aware
that you are going through this then
they can pray for you they can support
you they can you know still be there for
you like I was still there I was still
technically there for Nathaniel
because we because I accepted his dates
like I accepted his advances and so I
was still supporting him even though
that we were
separated um and like my story I don't
think is in some respects is not unique
but it's still everyone has their own
individual Journey on how it works
because everyone's individuals I did
like hearing that your husband said he
had had he had something positive to
fill that void because when you when
you're overcoming an addiction you might
be strong enough to do it in your own
strength for a short time you know week
two weeks months even but it's still
going to be aoid there and so for me I
had an alcohol addiction and when I I I
prayed and and surrendered and woke up
the next day without a single withdrawal
but the Temptation was still there you
know I didn't have God got me through
the with girls and so I got to the where
I would just drink a gallon of water a
day I was like I'm going to drink so
much water I can't even fit a beer in my
stomach so your husband was saying when
you leave sometimes I have that
Temptation and he doesn't just sit
around and twiddle his thumbs he's like
I'm going to read the Bible I'm going to
pray I'm going to go out in the garden
away from technology away from the
Temptation and do something positive to
fill that void we that's such a
important practical thing for people
that are overcoming addictions is to
fill that void with something positive
positive so I just wanted to bring that
up that you had said he did that and and
attaching to that as well um for the
person who is struggling with addiction
um it does come down to your mindset as
well um because even in the last few
months um Nathaniel really still
struggled with the shame and guilt
attached to it because he didn't want
people to think of that of him when they
first meet him or if they go and catch
up again he had in his head oh you know
they're looking at me this way because
of this addiction that I've had um and
in a lot of respects we kind of work
through it together um and came to a
point it's like well ultimately that's
their thoughts and they have every right
to their thoughts but it's in regards of
how you view yourself um and yeah you
can still you know even even though he
hasn't used in going on 0 months two
years now um he still had that
attachment of Shame attach to it um but
through our study of the Bible and to be
able to our attitudes about it we've
switched the whole instead of feeling
Shame about it it's like hey I can give
God the glory because he has helped me
through thisen um and I really wanted to
bring out um that as I guess from a
church perspective we need to be talking
about this and we need to be able to um
help people through these particular
addictions so that we can actually give
God the glory for helping us through and
that can go across the board to lots of
different things in our lives but by not
giving God the glory for helping
specifically Nathaniel to overcome he
was still I guess in some
respects being ashamed and down trotting
himself because of that
addiction um until he realized hey I
actually don't have to have shame for
that anymore because God has forgiven me
God has wiped away that sin and I can
actually now give God the glory for
helping me through and so as as people
we need to set aside the fact that you
know addiction is addiction but through
God all things are possible and we need
to give him the glory amen it really
reminds me as you're saying that of that
text in Revelation 14 I'm starting to
think of it a little bit differently
just now as you're saying that he says
in Revelation 14 um fear God and give
glory to him to the hour of his judgment
has come and you think well why why is
it time to give God glory when it's his
judgment hour but if you think about
what happens in God's
judgment God has been interceding on
behalf of his people and multiple times
in the Book of Revelation especially in
like chapters 2 and 3 it says to him who
overcomes right right Revelation 12 says
they overcame him by the blood of the
lamb and by the word of their
testimony if the Judgment the judgment
is essentially revealing what God has
done on behalf of his people to
exonerate them to wipe their slate clean
to put his robe of righteousness around
him I think this is a very good reason
to give God glory when you put it in
that light like yeah look at what he did
in the Judgment it's not like give God
glory he's going to like condemn
everybody now it's it's like no look how
he was able to be
righteous and still be a a judge and to
bestow that righteousness upon everybody
else and that's a that's a reason to
give the Lord Glory you know he's done
amazing things in people's lives so
that's right we are excited to hear of
how your story is ongoing and
progressing and that there is healing
and hope taking place so thank you for
sharing that and for sharing your
journey and uh just bringing up all the
little things that you've been dealing
with do you guys have any other
questions for Sam or maybe we can just
bring up some resources for people to
overcome pornography um you mentioned
fight the new drug fight the new drug
really good website um that has so much
information they're constantly updating
new information they have a podcast
called uh consider before
consuming and uh they also have a
specific web page on the website that's
called get the facts where anybody can
go on there and see the reasons for why
pornography is not healthy it's not
something you want to um you know be
dealing with even if you're not a
Christian like there should be reason
enough from the Bible alone that it's
adultery but if you're not a Christian
or need more resources boom boom boom
boom they're right there um what's the
other one oh Covenant eyes it's software
that put on your phone and on your
computer any all your devices all your
devices that basically you have an
accountability person as soon as
Covenant I picks something up it sends
it off to that accountability person
whether that's you or a friend or uh not
you it's your spouse or a friend or
whatever uh and then also I'm familiar
with uh well I know about Joshua broom
he is a former porn star who became a um
a Christian and a pastor
and on his website we can probably put
it right here he has a christian-based
program as well for overcoming
pornography uh I believe Sam you
mentioned your the one your dad has as
well uh could you tell us a little bit
about that so I'm pretty sure it's
called um road to recovery um but yeah
so that one was very helpful um for them
to be able to go through it because it's
specifically dealing with pornography
and masturbation um then also uh the
friend of mine that I spoke about she
sent me through um some resources that
she has been using that she's been
finding helpful um because now she
unfortunately she is now you know a
single mother and and trying to go
through all of that and dealing with the
past of all that and it's a website
called um Wilderness to Wild um and it's
basically support for um it is focused
on women um and women who have come
through a traumatic experience like this
um to be able to have resources on how
to connect back with God and how to
actually find Value um
you know of yourself in God um so that's
a good one that she uses I haven't
looked I have had a quick look on the
website myself but um she recommends it
and then you also mentioned that you are
going through a depression and anxiety
program because um you know I'm just
sitting here thinking like yes there are
other not to segregate this like it's a
a worse sin or something like that than
other things but unfortunately some of
the other things like let's pick on
gambling for second you know if you find
out your spouse has a gambling addiction
that doesn't have the same emotional
impact on the partner as a gambling
addiction does you know it doesn't
because there's there's that tendency to
respond just like you said you did with
i i my selfworth is now gone like I
don't feel valuable as a person anymore
because of the other person's actions so
um depression anxiety so you've got um
the Neil nedley depression recovery
program um is brilliant I've been
through that in the past like a few
years ago um separate to all this and
that's extremely good you know we hope
that this has been helpful to you I
think the one thing that Rings through
for me is that God is a god of hope God
is a god of healing and you know he
doesn't want to leave us the way that we
are no matter what it is that we're
dealing with God wants to Deliver Us
from that and that's what he came to do
is is to set the captives free so we
want to encourage you just like you've
heard from Sam you know seek help if you
need help if you find out there's a
problem and that doesn't it doesn't
matter what it is seek help and God will
lead you in the right direction so with
that we hope you like this video we hope
that you subscribe to our Channel and we
hope to see you again soon don't forget
that we are also uh a nonprofit you can
donate to Us online
ll. uh we also have uh patreon we also
have
pretty cool shirts I'm wearing one of
our sweatshirts anyway you can find
those on lightwear shop and so thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
in the near future as soon as next week
we'll see you next
[Music]
time
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the
[Music]
world every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know you're
thinking of
them every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in
[Music]
return
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help
them every day is an
opportunity to do one small
thing to show someone you
care to make the world a better
place
[Music]
oh